right now there is a massive paragraph
happening a battle for which AI
companies will reign supreme and whoever
comes out on top will have more
influence over Society than any leader
dictator or politician before them along
with billions of dollars added to their
names whoever comes out on top will be
the new modern day feudal Lords while
the rest of the masses the new modern
day serves but it won't be just
billionaires that will be minted now
this Revolution Will usher in a new era
of millionaires and multi-millionaires
generational wealth is here for the
taking and if you don't want to be
fending for scraps then you better act
fast that's why in this video me and
Leora are going to go over what to do
right now if you're technical what
opportunities there are for you if
you're not Technical and much more and
because Leora is actually in the
trenches every day studying the stuff
reading the research papers seeing the
trends you're gonna hear a ton of stuff
that you're not going to hear anywhere
else I learned a ton just from making
this video so you are not gonna want to
miss a second of it stay dangerous and
this is how to use this AI Revolution to
make generational wealth
thank you
[Music]
if you want to understand how to make
money off of AI no matter if you're
technical or not you have to first
understand what made chat gbt go viral
in the first place
so what's very interesting if you
noticed I said that openai released
their first GPT language model paper in
2018 right we're in 2023 so what
happened basically they went through
version one GPT one gpt2 GPT 3 and then
GPT 3.5 and then gpt4 but GPT existed
from 2000 so why did it hit now why was
now the big why did it have such a big
impact now and the reason is that they
created the interface and the genius of
openai's there's some credit to the
model of course but the genius is that
they understood that having an easy to
use frictionless interface is much more
valuable than a very Advanced AI model
think about the fact that you don't even
need to take care of punctuations or
typos when you're at HTTP that's crazy
that's that means that anyone in the
world can now write broken English and
make it work and so that's what's very
remarkable what they did so to answer
your question I think there's a lot a
lot a lot of opportunity communities and
taking AI complexity models and making
it more available understandable and
democratizing it to the average
population I think that's going to
benefit everyone and I think this is
where most of opportunities are I think
just taking those models understanding
them and saying hey this could be
applied there this could help for trauma
this could help for therapy this could
help for finance this could help for
lawyers so I think that's more
interesting chat gbt blew up because it
removed friction it allowed the common
man to use it without any technical
knowledge whatsoever and it's a lesson
that you can borrow from
the easiest way to profit from the AI
Revolution is to Simply bet on the
companies that are investing into Ai and
the easiest way to do that is with
something called a ttf ttfs are themed
stock collections for example there's an
AI and machine learning theme ttf and by
investing in this ttf you get exposure
to the biggest players in AI nothing
more and nothing less that way instead
of spending hours researching individual
stocks or investing in a giant ETF with
hundreds of stocks that are not relevant
you can just invest in a hyper focused
ttf made up of just 10 to 15 companies
in that Niche there's an AI one a gold
mining ttf a crispr gene editing ttf a
crypto Mining ttf and much more there's
even a military and defense ttf which is
very on brand for this channel wink wink
so if ttf sound interesting to you pause
the video and click the link below to
download gaming to see all the TTS they
have to offer Guinea are the pioneers of
ttfs so you're not going to find ttfs
anywhere else they're also registered
with the SEC and your money is FDIC
insured so click the link below and
check out all the ttfs Gainey has to
offer now I am not a registered
financial advisor this is not Financial
advice and thanks to Gainey for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
you still believe that's the way to go I
still believe that the best way to take
advantage of the AI wave or not take
advantage but more like you know get
into Ai and do work and progress in AI
is to wrap the complex research and
models and tools into user-friendly
interfaces for the general population
and you know they say that every
successful technology is seamless so the
Wi-Fi the you know 5G 4G you don't feel
it you don't feel the difference and
that's what's going to happen it's
already happening with AI is everywhere
it's on your iPhone it's you know on
this computer it's probably AI is
probably recording my voice right now
and coding and decoding it and improving
it and so that's what's going to happen
so we have a seamless integration of AI
into our society and I think if we can
help that to go faster and if you can
help Society 2 or AI to get into society
faster there's a lot of opportunities
there all you have to do is find ways
understand what AI can do it cannot do
everything understand what it can and
cannot do once you understand that find
Opportunities where you can take that
solution and apply it to that could be
I've seen it done everywhere I've seen
it done you know in uh autonomous trucks
uh Freight control you know planes it
could be Amazon uses it to you know sort
their merchandise so you just need to
find a way to apply it but I do think
that there's a lot of opportunities to
do that if someone knows like the basis
of coding like they know python or
whatever how do you recommend they learn
about AI specifically like the technical
aspects of it if you know Python and you
want to get started I think the number
one thing you have to start doing is
understanding what it does you can skip
the Theory actually what I recommend is
to do a hybrid between theory and
practice where you can go on a YouTube
channel and have someone code a neural
network from scratch and go through the
theory at the same time and so what I
recommend is to start implementing right
now so you want to understand how neural
network works you know how to code okay
code one you know develop one it's like
25 lines of code you can do it just
Google it to find ways to do it and you
start like that and you build on top
okay now I know how to do a neural
network how could I do a neural network
that can understand images like a CNN
it's called a convolutional neural
network and you code it and you go to
Next Level okay I want to do you know
videos it's the next level and then you
start like that there's also a lot of
websites like kaggle which are pretty
cool uh kaggle is a website where
companies have ai and data science
problems and they say okay we have this
problem this is our data side fixing
like find a solution and then you have
like millions of people throughout the
world that are trying to solve that and
the one who wins gets like a lot of
money and so what's cool is that once
the competition is done or even before
you can put your solution public so what
you have is like you have people that
are super smart with years and Decades
of experience telling you exactly how to
solve a problem and they have their
solution and their code and most of the
time they're walking you through the
code oh so that's a great way to to get
started and to understand what each line
if code does so if you want to go down
this technical routes Learn Python learn
the basis of how to code a neural Nets
learn from websites like kaggle that
have competitions to solve AI problems
and once you have that Foundation it's
time to start finding an everyday
problem that you can solve with AI and
the biggest Niche that's popping off
right now that investors are throwing a
ton of money at are generative AI
startups
thank you
[Music]
where's the world of AI generative AI
startups looking like right now is it
like popping off a lot of investors
we're seeing a lot of funding and money
being thrown out to caravai I think
there was a recent report showing that
the Y combinator had you know at least a
quarter I think a quarter or a third of
their batch of winter 2023 being
generative AI which is crazy two years
ago it was zero so can imagine how every
investor is betting on the future of
narrative Ai and also you know we have
companies like complexity who just
raised you know 26 million dollars you
have stability there's big companies a
lot of funding flowing to AI but you
know one thing is interesting is that
when I look at the numbers they're good
numbers so we do still feel the
recession the numbers are still lower
than two years ago but money I think is
still being pushed in Ai and we're still
because people believe in it people
believe it's the future I think the
economy can go up and down it's still
the future so that's why like
everybody's starting to push towards
that direction and perhaps the greatest
example of an AI startup entrepreneur is
a guy named Alexander Wang the youngest
self-made billionaire in the world at
only 25 years old
[Music]
Alexander Weiss company is called scale
Ai and although you may not know his
name his face or even his company yet he
just became the youngest self-made
billionaire in the world thanks to his
work in AI what did he create that was
so valuable simple he solved a big AI
related pain point for big businesses
that no one else was paying attention to
scale AI is the data infrastructure for
AI to power the most ambitious AI
projects in the world every organization
wants to implement AI but oftentimes the
the biggest bottleneck in their way is
being able to create really high quality
data and data sets to power that AI at
scale we sort of view data as the the
core problem of building great AI
whereas a lot of other companies view it
as an afterthought and that really
prevents AI from having sort of the
magnitude of outcomes that it's able to
have we've raised over 600 million
dollars to date and we work with
everywhere from the largest automakers
in the world like Toyota and General
Motors to the United States Department
of Defense to some of the largest
Enterprise in the world like Microsoft
square and PayPal and some of the
leading AI research organizations like
so so far we've covered what to do if
you're technical if you're into coding
but what if you're not technical at all
well we have good news for you because
AI is about to usher in a whole new era
for entrepreneurship
yeah I think it's the same as I said
it's like hopping Society crossover like
Implement yeah seamlessly oh you don't
need to be technical to do that you you
just have to team up with someone that
is maybe technical or you can take
pre-packaged AI you know you can take
charge upt for example and create an
agency around it and go to companies and
say hey I can solve x y and z problem
and you in the back end run charging PT
and now what you're going to have is you
know a reduction of the team size AI is
going to go so 15 years ago 100 years
ago we had companies with 600 thousands
of employees and then with the internet
it just got smaller and now with AI it's
going to get even smaller so now you can
run like a multi-million dollar company
with 10 people I think when the age of
AI you're gonna need three people and
you know if you're not technical then
all you have to do is be a bridge
between service or product and Ai and
you can go anywhere and and use AI you
just need to know the tools and then you
can create you know something around it
like a wrapper around it and then you
know give clients like that you can use
AI to reduce expenses uh so what's going
to happen what's going to happen is that
you have a lot of businesses that
require like a good amount of initial
capital and so what AI could do is
reduce that amount and now what you're
going to have is like more and more
people getting into business because I
need to hire a lawyer anymore I can
maybe take an initial version on the
internet and then have chat GPT go
through it and adapt it to my problem or
I don't need to hire a web developer
because I can you know ask jgpt to
develop the website and so what's going
to happen is that more and more people
that are non-technical will be able to
get into business because they'll be
assisted by AI to develop websites to
review contracts or to write job posters
to do copywriting so there's a lot of
opportunities there for sure but it's
not just entrepreneurs here are just a
few use cases to get your juices flowing
PhD students are already using AI to
organize their thesis research and help
them learn Chinese doctors are using it
to transcribe their patients visits into
clinical notes and to appeal Insurance
denial one senior researcher at the Bio
Innovation Institute used AI to create
new proteins after doing protein
research for a decade he said he's never
been more efficient in his whole career
it's crazy everything is becoming much
easier just the funny thing I read
recently is actually maybe I said it it
was cha GPT just killed the writer's
block writer's block is not going to
exist anymore it's going to be something
of the past because all you have to do
if you don't know how to write is to say
I don't want to write this help me
sketch it out and you know it's going to
do it's going to help you move forward
in your writing so I think it could help
everyone
but aside from everything we just talked
about the most important thing that you
can be doing right now is to just stay
up to date with the latest developments
in AI that way you can see what
industries are getting disrupted you can
avoid being on the short end of the
stick you can see new business
opportunities pop up that weren't there
just a few months ago but the problem is
the AI field is moving way too fast for
anyone to be able to keep up with
so one of the biggest problems happening
with AI right now and it's been
happening for the last you know few
years is the speed of progress so as I
said there's like around 2000 research
papers being published every week and
probably the same amount of GitHub repos
and codes and models so here's what lior
did he built an AI model to monitor
everything happening on the internet in
regards to AI he then feeds it into a
database and ranks it by importance that
way you go from 2 000 research papers to
just three the problem is these three
research papers are still really hard
for someone like you and me to
understand so me and lior were talking
and we concluded that there needs to be
a solution for this there needs to be a
place for the average person to go to to
learn about the latest developments in
AI without needing a PhD that's why
we're excited to announce the new Alpha
signal YouTube channel where every week
we take the biggest AI developments that
just happened and explain how it's going
to impact the world in videos that even
a 5 year old can understand in our first
video on this new channel is on a brand
new AI tool that just dropped called
drag Dan and it's being called the
Photoshop killer take a look and you can
watch our new video on now right now by
clicking the card on the screen click
the card on the screen to watch now
[Music]
foreign